من عانه والله مش من حرب واحد من عده حروب
من الميه حرب قله الاكل حرب قله العلاج
حرب قله المكان كمان فيش مكان نقعد فيه
يعني احنا عارف يمكن اربع او خمس اماكن
تنقلنا من مدرسه لمدرسه لمكان لمكان لما
لقينا هذا المكان ومش امن كمان يعني فيش
امان ولا في اي مكان امان بس خلص سبحان
الله من حالات الروح الواحد بتنقل من مكان
لمكان طبخنا رز على ميه والحمد لله ان
احنا بلاقيه يعني لما راح ابني يمكن قاعد
ثلاث ساعات لما جاب كيلو الرز لما نلاقيه
في الدكان ما فيش دكين بس يعني من مكان
لمكان لما نلقاه والحمد لله بس نضن على
هيك الحمد
لله لا اله الا الله الصغار والله العظيم
يعني كثير نشفين رقنا من قله المكان
يلعبوا يطلعوا من قله الاكل وكمان دائما
عينين ما فيش علاجات والله الصدريات خلص
ما فيش صدريات ولا ع ولا عيادات
والمستشفيات كله خراب ودمار واش عرفه اللي
عمر سنه وسنتين وثلاثه وكمان يمكن لثمان
سنين او ع سنين بس بده ياكل يلعب غير هيك
لا